call of duty mobile is unique because it
really allows us to reach an entirely
different audience a much more globally
diverse audience season eight for this
year is the train of nowhere and this is
the first time we've ever done a spy
themed season it's really cool to kind
of imagine sort of going behind the rope
of
you know james bond universe and that
sort of trouble you can get into
in that sort of fantasy world the battle
pass features weapons like the zrg 20
millimeter bolt action sniper rifle
we have a all new spy operators we have
new season event around called spy
hunter there's a new
class in battle royale
that allows you to
also live out the spy fantasy so we're
really going deep with this integration
project aurora is our
next project in the call of duty mobile
ecosystem it's something we've been
taking all the learning from the past
several years operating call of duty
mobile learning what we wish we could do
if we were creating something new
looking at what players really liked the
most and things that we maybe were never
really able to do in the first place the
first time around so that kind of
learning is precious and we have you
know talent
the years of experience on operating
that style of game to open our eyes to
what's possible there's also a lot of
really cool innovation happening in the
call of duty franchise and you put those
two things together the learning that
we've had over the past several years
plus all the new evolutions that are
happening at call of duty franchise we
saw it as an opportunity to really bring
a next generation experience to mobile
players we have four internal studios
that are developing the title it's a lot
of really talented people from all
around the world at different studios
all coming together to make something
that really requires that level of
effort it's actually in a private alpha
right now so a lot of real players are
already helping us
by you know playing it every day and
giving us feedback to help improve it
the teams are right now you know play
testing and working every day
to continue to bring project aurora
further along
and we're excited to be able to show a
lot more about the project very very
soon our core experience here is to
bring warzone to mobile for the first
time um and that has a lot of
interesting challenges to it because the
scale and ambition that warzone has
always
had when it was first introduced and we
want to do that justice i'm
happy to announce that the real title
for project aurora is call of duty
warzone mobile and you'll be able to see
more about that title live
at an event called next
which is a call of duty franchise event
that's going to reveal the future of
call of duty
there's a lot of exciting stuff that's
going to happen that's september 15th
you can go to the call of duty official
youtube channel or twitch to see it live
we will be showing call of duty wars on
mobile there
among many other revelations so we're
super excited to announce the title and
to show everybody
later this month
you